[Music]  the Yukon is a dangerous place you never  know what's coming I came up here  because I didn't want to be around  anyone and then I met buck he was a dog  like no other we've been spoiled  Jenova and it suffered  [Music]  but he could not be broken  I don't know where you came from but I  know where you are now welcome to the  last place on the earth I should let him  have a minute doesn't look like he's  ever seen snow before how do you feel  about an adventure  Oh maps we should go you and I or no  one's ever been before  see what's out there  glad you're enjoying this  I never saw him believe in anything as  much as he believes in you  [Music]  what do you say buck  adventure of a lifetime  [Applause]  you know sleeping for two days in my bed  [Music]